There were some
other questions sort
of running along this
general idea of the fact
that the information
in DNA doesn't go,
even though it encodes the
information for proteins
goes via this rRNA intermediate.
Someone asked what was the M.
The M is for messenger.
The idea being
that since the DNA,
at least in eukaryotes
the DNA was in the nucleus
and proteins were made
out of the cytoplasm,
somehow that information had
to be carried from the nucleus
where the DNA was
out to the cytoplasm.
And that's where
the term messenger
was because the RNA was
seen as something that would
carry the information out.
Now, a point here,
it's really critical
because we're going to continue
to talk about gene regulation.
And that is when a cell is
making one of these mRNAs,
it doesn't make one single
copy of all of the genes
that are in the
genome on one RNA.
Instead it does it either
one gene at a time,
which is the usual
case, or occasionally
as we see in the lac operon
a little tiny cluster of DNAs
that have related functions.
And the beauty of
that is that it then
enables the cell to dial in
how much protein is being made,
in part at least, by determining
how much RNA is being made.
So you're going to make no RNA
and not make the protein at all
or make a little RNA and
get a little protein,
or if it's really
a thing you need
very large quantities of you can
really crank out a lot of RNA
and make a lot of protein.
So the potential is
there for regulation.
And in bacteria, as I said,
for almost all bacterial genes
it's pretty straightforward.
You can look in the
DNA, and at least
if you know where to start,
see the start of a protein,
you can just use that
table of the genetic code
and read off the sequence.
But eukaryotes in particular,
higher eukaryotes have this odd
business that what seemed odd
and surprising that when you
look at their genes, many
of them you cannot do that
because it's as if there
are extra bits of DNA stuck
in the middle.
And in some cases
you heard it could
be really huge amounts of DNA so
that there is this extra thing
where there's a pre mRNA.
And this RNA splicing we
talked about has to take place
to generate the mRNA.
And once you have the mRNA then
the ribosome and the charge
tRNAs can be used to
make the proteins.
And someone asked what
all that extra DNA is for.
I mean we still don't
fully understand that.
There are some
regulatory sequences
and regulatory actors that are
buried in that non coding DNA.
But another thing may
be that this is just
the way it's worked
in evolution.
And as long as it works
there's no driving force
necessarily to get rid of it.
If you look at
microorganisms, for example,
yeast is a eukaryotic
that, like E. coli,
has to replicate
pretty fast in order
to compete with other
microorganisms for the food
and whatnot in its environment.
And it has relatively little
of these extra intervening
sequences compared to
what we find in our DNA.
I gave you the
example of Factor 8.
It didn't really particularly
matter what it was in the sense
that it was just an example
of something that has
a lot of intervening sequence.
What it is, though,
it's one of a set
of proteins that are involved
in clotting of your blood.
When you cut yourself,
we have this system
that prevents us from
bleeding to death,
unless you have hemophilia or
something like that where's
there's a problem with
the clotting system,
then a very complex
set of things happen.
And Factor 8 is one of
the several proteins that
play critical roles in that.
Somebody asked, I talked
about a few things
that were, this was
sort of the dogma.
This was how information
was thought to go.
And then how Dave
Baltimore found
there was reverse transcriptase
that could take an RNA
and make a DNA copy.
And the question was
they didn't understand
how the dogma could change.
I mean that's sort
of what I'm trying
to emphasize a
lot in this course
is what I'm teaching you is
what human experimentation
and thought has
brought up until spring
of 2005 of terms in biology.
Some of the sort of
basic discoveries
were made in physics
so long ago that it's
very unlikely that you'll
come in and discover
that the Newtonian mechanics
you learned as a freshman is not
operative anymore
when you're a senior,
but you can still have these
massive revolutions in biology
where just suddenly whole
things, like RNA splicing,
emerge from the woodwork
almost overnight.
And that's, in fact,
what happened with that.
That's what happened with
reverse transcriptase.
So, in a sense,
it's almost a joke
that Crick called it dogma.
He didn't know
what he was doing.
But it sort of took
that property on.
And I'm trying to caution you
that even though some of you
would like me to
stick to just facts
that we're continually
learning and there
are discoveries being
made even as we're
going on with this course.
Now, I told you that there
were certain viruses, HIV
being the one I
really emphasized,
that have this property.
Their genetic
material is not DNA.
It's RNA.
And the reverse transcriptase
makes a double strand copy
that it inserts into
the organism's DNA
and becomes a permanent part.
And I'm trying to
caution you that's why
safe sex is such a big deal.
Because if you get
infected with HIV
you'll have it for
the rest of your life.
I mentioned there were
some cancer viruses,
and someone said,
well, if you do
that how can you cure cancer?
Well, in fact, we're
lucky in the sense
that we don't have to contend
at this point in a major way
with human cancer viruses, that
would be more of a problem,
but your cats have to.
You may have heard of the
feline leukemia virus.
This is a retrovirus
of this same class,
and cats infected with it
have it in their saliva.
And although it
can be transmitted
amongst pets in
the same household,
the big problem is
usually cat fights.
And then you get a scratch
and then it gets in.
So if you have a
cat you probably
had to take it to the
vet and get vaccinated.
And one of the reasons
is you're trying
to get it vaccinated against
the feline leukemia virus.
And it's just sort of
like that story I told you
with the streptococcus, that
if your immune system has
seen the thing beforehand
then if you actually
get an infection it has
a very quick response
and your cat doesn't get
infected by the virus.
And therefore doesn't
become a candidate
for getting leukemia
in later life.
OK.
So at least there's an effort
to try and response to at least
a few of the things.
There were some very interesting
and thoughtful questions.
So I want to now go back
to talk a little bit more
about this issue of
regulation because that is one
of the real secrets to life.
And it's the
ability of organisms
to turn on and off
certain functions
and to have rheostats
where the can control
the levels of expression.
But all of this has
to be in the DNA.
And so before people
knew how this worked,
it's a little mysterious.
And maybe one way you
might think about it, well,
if I have a gene that
encodes something
for lactose metabolism,
and I tell you there's
a sequence upstream of this and
somehow this gene is regulated
depending on whether I put
lactose in the medium or not,
how is it going to work?
Does it have to fit
into little holes
in between the letters
of the genetic code
sort of the way Gamov
originally thought about it,
or is there some
other mechanism?
And what you'll see here is
one of the general strategies
that evolution has chosen
is although there's
regulatory information
in the DNA,
DNA isn't a particularly
good molecule for recognizing
things, but what it is good
at is encoding proteins.
So the trick is to
have some proteins made
whose role in life
are to be regulators.
So that this is
what is underlying
this system that I started
to tell you about on Friday.
So remember -- -- beta
galactosidase is the enzyme
that takes lactose which is
lactose beta 1,4 glucose.
And somebody said it's
easy to get them mixed up.
I apologize, but
those are the names.
And cleaves it,
just breaks the bond
to give galactose plus glucose.
Both of those can be
metabolized by ordinary elements
you'll find in most cells.
But taking lactose, which
you also know as milk sugar
because it's in milk,
needs this extra function.
If you're lactose intolerant,
as a fraction of you
will be because that's quite
common in the human population,
then, although you had the
enzyme when you were baby,
it's been shut off in
your body since then
and it causes problems.
Because if you eat lactose,
drink milk or something,
the lactose goes right
through your stomach
and ends up in your intestine.
And there are bacteria in there
that are able to break it open.
And when they do that it leads
to gas and some other sort
of uncomfortablenesses
that are associated
with lactose intolerance.
So, as I'd said,
the major finding
was that this enzyme beta
galactosidase or beta
gal was regulated.
That if you grow E.
coli on glucose -- --
there was no beta gal.
And if you grow them on
lactose as the carbon source
then there were high
levels of beta gal.
And that then lead Jacques
Monod and Francois Jacob,
the two French
scientists I mentioned,
to begin studying this problem.
And, like so many
things in biology,
they were working
on a huge problem,
how are genes regulated?
But it wasn't so evident
at the beginning.
What they were doing was
this very modest thing,
why is beta galactosidase
there in one condition and not
another?
Just a little problem
in bacterial metabolism.
And ultimately it
gave us the roots
to the answer of how
genes are regulated.
And I just have to leave out
all the beautify stuff that
led to what they found.
Let me just recapitulate what I
put on the board the other day.
It turned out that the LacC
gene, this is the gene that
encodes beta
galactosidase, so that's
the sequence, that has
the sequence of codons,
that if you could
start at the beginning
and go along and just put all
the amino acids in you would
end up with beta galactosidase.
That unit of
genetic information,
which is called the lacC
gene, let's put it here.
Then there were two
other genes just
downstream of this in the DNA.
And this unit is made
as a single mRNA.
So this is a little bit
different than what I told you.
It's not just one gene.
It's actually two or three
because these bacteria
try to do everything very
efficiently because they're
growing quickly.
This means it can turn on
three genes of related function
very efficiently.
When you have several genes that
are expressed using one mRNA,
as I said, the genes are said
to be organized in an operon.
But the key point that
we talked about before is
you're going to have these
genes expressed everything
has to be written in the DNA.
And it's not using
the genetic code.
It's using other words
that are written there.
And you've seen this word
now in several lectures.
That's a promoter.
And that means to
start transcription.
And to stop the
mRNA there has to be
something at the other end.
And I'll show you the
sequence of at least one
of these promoters in a minute.
This means to stop
transcription,
to stop making the RNA copy.
If you didn't have
sequences like
that the cell wouldn't know
where should I begin the RNA
and where does it end.
And since there are
many, many genes,
there have to be many
promoters and many terminators.
And the other point
I tried to hammer
home the other day is although
the genetic code is universal,
you can take that little
table and read the sequence
of human proteins or E.
coli proteins, these
other languages
that are written using this four
letter nucleic acid alphabet
are not universal.
So the sequences that E.
coli uses for a promoter,
a start transcription are
very different than what
our bodies use as a start
transcription thing.
And when we get to the
recombinant DNA stuff
that will be an issue.
So this mRNA is then
used to make proteins.
This would be beta galactosidase
or the lac Z gene product,
and these other genes make,
so these are proteins.
Here you see this flow of
information from the DNA
through the mRNA down to
being made into proteins.
In the case of bacteria
there's no nucleus.
Everything is in one big
pot so that mRNA doesn't
have to go anywhere,
but it's all there
and it gets translated to
give copies of the protein.
So, as I said,
somehow if the cell
is going to now regulate whether
these genes are expressed
or not, depending on
whether lactose is present.
And the way they do it
makes perfect sense.
Don't bother to make
the enzyme if there's
no lactose in the
neighborhood, and only
make it if it's present.
So how are they
going to do that?
Is the lactose going
to come along and stick
into some little hole
here or something?
That's not a general
strategy and it
wouldn't work if you look at
the structure of DNA anyway.
It wouldn't have access
to the sequence of bases.
So what was discovered was that
there was another gene very
close called lacI.
And the protein that it encodes
is called the lac repressor.
And since it's a gene it
has to have a promoter,
a start transcription.
But this one, be careful now,
don't get yourself mixed up,
this is for the lacI gene.
This is a different promoter
over here for this thing.
And then there is
also then a terminator
or a stop transcription.
And, again, this is
for the lacI gene.
So this gets made
into an mRNA as well.
And this gets translated
into a protein
that's known as lac repressor.
And what that lac repressor
has is the ability to bind
to a particular sequence in
DNA that's located right here.
This is a binding site right
here for lac repressor.
So let me just try
to blow that up
just a little bit because
this could be a little bit
confusing.
So here's the promoter --
-- for this LacCYA operon.
Here's the beginning
of the LacC gene.
And so this is where
the RNA polymerase,
the machine that's going to
make the RNA copy has to bind.
And here's the binding site.
-- for lac repressor
or the lacI protein.
So how does this circuit work?
And I sort of pose that as
an issue for those of you
who had followed it at
least to that point.
So let's consider
the two situations.
If there's no
lactose present what
we know from just scientists
knew from experimentation
was there was no
beta galactosidase
activity inside the cell.
You could crack them open and
you wouldn't find this enzyme
there.
And when you added
lactose they knew,
from that experiment
described on Friday,
it was synthesized de novo.
So if there's no
lactose present --
And what happens is we have the
lacI gene, mRNA is being made,
this lac repressor
is being made,
here's the promoter for LacCYA,
and here's the sequence.
And this repressor goes
up and binds to that.
And by binding to this
particular sequence
what it does is it
covers up the promoter.
It covers up the start
signal, the signal
that says "start
transcription here".
Are you guys with me?
It's a relatively
simple strategy.
It's just by lac repressor
having that ability
to bind to a particular
sequence it's
able to prevent
the RNA polymerase
from seeing the promoter.
And therefore it's
able to prevent
the RNA from being made.
So there's no mRNA.
And if there's no mRNA
over here then there's
no beta galactosidase
being made.
This is an exercise in futility.
Why has the cell gone and
made this useless protein
that isn't doing anything
in terms of helping
it metabolize lactose?
But now take a
look at the system
compared to what I described
when we were first doing it.
If we had to do all
the regulation directly
with the DNA we
have this problem
that lactose would
somehow have to be
able to see a sequence in
DNA and somehow determine
what happened.
But what this cell
has done now is
it's set this system
up so that the ability
to make lactose or
not make lactose
is conditional on this protein
called the lac repressor.
If lac repressor is
bound, as it's shown here,
it's basically covering
up the promoter,
the cell cannot make RNA and
cannot make beta galactosidase.
If it was absent, if we just
got rid of lac repressor
then the promoter
would be exposed
and the cell could make
beta galactosidase.
And so it's now lac repressor
that has the conditionality.
It's, in essence, a sensor.
It can at least be
considered a sensor
for whether lactose is present.
And indeed that is the property
that lac repressor has.
It's able to bind lactose.
So if we think lactose
is present what happens?
I mean this lacI gene is
a pretty uninteresting,
uninteresting from the
standpoint of regulation
in the sense that it's
made all the time.
The cell just continually cranks
out a bit of lac repressor.
It doesn't need very much.
It just needs to make enough
so that the one binding
site for lac repressor
has somebody bound to it.
So it can get away
with pretty low levels.
But over here then we
have this promoter,
and we have the LacC
gene and so on here,
and there is the binding
sequence right there.
But this lac repressor has
the ability to bind lactose,
which I'm going to draw
as a little triangle here,
even though you know
it's a disaccharide.
It has a different property.
But the fundamental
characteristic
of the lac repressor
binding lactose
is it undergoes a
change in confirmation.
So if it's got a binding
pocket, and lactose
fits into that
binding pocket, those
alpha helices and beta
sheets and so on move
around a little bit.
And what happens
then is it perturbs
the part of the protein
that would normally
be able to recognize
this DNA sequence.
And this cannot -- -- bind
to the DNA sequence up here.
And I'll tell you the special
name for that binding site.
It's just one of these terms
that you'll see in biology.
Everything has to
be given a name.
It's called an operator,
for historical reasons.
But, in any case,
the lac repressor,
once it's hanging
onto a lactose it's
unable to bind this sequence.
That means that the start site
for transcription is made.
And so you get the
mRNA made and then
you get beta
galactosidase present.
A little bit complicated,
but sort of underlying it
is this idea that
now the cell is
using a protein rather
than DNA to tell
whether lactose is present.
And hopefully you can see
this is really general now
because you can design
a regulatory protein.
And basically it's got
to have two things.
It's got to have a part
that talks to the DNA
and recognizes some
sequence, and it's
got to have another part
that senses whatever it is.
Histidine, temperature,
you name it.
But once you understand
that design principle then
you can begin to see how
it is that the cell is
able to turn genes on and off
just by encoding information
in the DNA.
And, as I say, one
of the big tricks
there is to let the protein
do the sensing for you.
Now, I just want to give you a
little bit of a blowup of what
this things looks like.
Because sort of all
I've done is kind of
put it here as a sequence.
I've called it a promoter.
What a promoter
then is, again it
means the start
for transcription,
the process of making RNA.
And I've tried to stress
that these promoters are not
universal.
So when I tell you this for E.
coli, this is what a promoter
for E. coli looks like,
but it doesn't look at all
like a promoter in our bodies.
And so it's basically
a word that's
written using this
nucleic acid alphabet.
And it looks
something like this.
There's TTGACA and then there
are about 17 base pairs that
can be just about anything.
And then there's TATAAT.
And then there's
another little bit here
that's about ten
base pairs long.
And then this is the start
of the mRNA which is usually
given the convention of being
called the plus one position.
So you'll notice this word
I've called it, written,
that says start transcription
has even got two parts to it.
And this is usually referred
to the minus ten region
of the promoter, and this
is the minus 35 region
because that's the distance
from the start of transcription.
It maybe seem sort of
weird to you to see
what I'm telling you
is sort of word written
in the nucleic acid language.
It's got some bits in the
middle that don't matter.
But remember the DNA is a
helix and things going around
like this.
So if you were just
to take a DNA helix
and then lay something
down on one side of it,
it would contact it here, it
wouldn't contact it there,
and then when it came back up
again it would contact it here.
And so as these things hang
on along the sides of DNA
it's not at all uncommon to
find this sort of broken where
you can have something
that matters,
something that doesn't
matter and something
that matters again.
The RNA polymerase in
E. coli, it's a machine.
It's got four proteins
that are the core.
That's the part that
actually synthesizes
the RNA plus one protein, which
is known as the sigma subunit.
And it has the special job
of recognizing the promoter.
And so when we
start asking where
does this regulatory sequence
that the lac repressor
binds it in all of this.
It turns out that the sequence
for binding lac repressor -- --
overlaps with this
minus ten region.
So when the lac
repressor is sitting down
it's covering up a
very important part
of transcription.
You guys with me?
OK.
So this is an interesting
kind of regulation.
It's given the general term
-- -- negative regulation.
And the reason that
term is applied,
it means that the
regulatory protein -- --
interferes with transcription.
And let's take a
brief foray into we're
going to talk about genetics
as our next subject.
And I think maybe we can
let you sort of already
get a sense of how some
of this was figured out.
So there's a substance
called X gal, which
is a galactose with some
chemical entity hanging off
that's colorless.
But yet it's a
substrate textbook.
And so if we grow E.
coli on plates that
have glucose plus X gal,
the colonies would be we
learn all this kind of thing.
It just doesn't
come out of a whose
bond can be cleaved
by beta galactosidase.
experimentally I'm
not doing too good
a job of conveying
to you how colorless.
And if we were to
grow them on plates
that had lactose plus but
I think if you don't have
some sense of how this is done
Someone said they
thought this was
too much lab stuff, X gal
then all of the colonies
would be colored
because they're making
And this is a very useful thing
for bacterial geneticists.
And it gives galactose
plus the free X entity.
And this is colored.
beta galactosidase.
And part of the way that
this stuff that I've
been telling you was figured
out was by bacterial geneticists
looking for something.
What they looked
for was back here
on this plate that had Xgal.
Almost all the colonies
were colorless.
These were colored because they
could make beta galactosidase.
So if I gave you some plates
of this, you looked in the lab
and then you found a colored
colony, it's a mutant.
I'll define these terms
for you very shortly.
But it's got an alteration
in the DNA that affects
the regulation -- -- of beta
gal or the product of the lacC
gene.
And on the basis of what I've
told you about this model,
can you guys come up with two
types of things, two places
or kinds of mutations that
could break this system that
would lead to beta galactosidase
being on even though there's
no lactose in the medium?
Anybody see one of them?
Why is it off?
Because of lac repressor?
In a wild type strain
it's because lac repressor
is bound to that
sequence and it's
shutting off transcription.
So we had a variant that
could now transcribe.
Yeah.
OK, so that's a good idea.
So if we could somehow mutate
that little binding sequence
in a way that didn't screw
up everything else then,
even though there was
lac repressor being made,
if it couldn't bind here because
the sequence had been changed
then you'd get it made.
That's exactly right.
That's one of them.
Yeah.
OK, it was a
problem making lacI.
What would happen?
Well, if we couldn't make this
and it couldn't bind there
we'd be on.
And that's the other class.
Can you think of
a kind of mutation
that we learned
about, think back
to the genetic code,
that would prevent
lac repressor from being made?
I'm trying to give you a clue.
There were 61 codons
encoded for amino acids.
Yeah.
Oh, that would work.
Yup, if we messed
up the promoter.
That's a sophisticated answer.
Yeah, if we messed up the
promoter for making lacI
that would certainly give that.
Can you think of
another type of thing
that would affect the lacI
gene, would prevent lacI
from being made?
Somebody?
Yeah.
OK.
If the sequence was wrong
so that they could bind,
that would be good.
The one I'm trying
to tease out of you,
but I won't take longer now,
is remember those three stop
codons that didn't
encode for anything?
There should be one of those
at the end of the protein.
But if you changed
one of the amino acid
codons into a stop
codon that would also
prevent you from making it.
So there are at least a
couple of kinds of mutations.
And what I've sort
of done here is
I've skipped all the evidence
and given you the model.
And I cannot give you all the
evidence that lead to this,
which is a pretty well
established model.
I don't think this is
going to change likely.
We've been studying
it for so long.
But this is the kind of
evidence on which it was based.
In was by people finding
things and figuring out
that parts of the machinery
were broken and then working on.
So there's another
kind of regulation
known as positive regulation.
And for a long time people
though maybe everything
was negative regulation.
But it turns out positive
regulation is far more common.
In this case, the
regulatory protein
instead of inhibiting
transcription
assists with the transcription.
And it turned out,
after people had
been studying the
beta galactosidase
system for a number of years,
that it had a positive control
system superimposed or together
with the negative regulatory
system.
The same thing engineers
do all the time,
pile up regulatory
circuits and get all kinds
of additional conditionalities.
And the thing I've
told you saw far
was we asked whether
beta gal is present.
And the carbon source
-- -- is glucose.
This is low or not there.
If it's lactose it's high, but
if cells were grown on both,
glucose plus lactose, then beta
galactosidase is low again.
And this makes some
physiological sense because E.
coli likes to use galactose.
It's its favorite food source.
And so if it's got its favorite
food source around then
it doesn't want to
make proteins that
are used to eat all its sort
of less favorite food source.
So there's a nice
conditionality here.
In order for it,
the circuitry is
set up so that it only makes the
enzyme for metabolizing lactose
when the cell realizes its
favorite food source isn't
there and then it
senses there's lactose.
So only under those conditions
does it make the enzymes
for making lactose.
And, again, the way
this circuitry works,
this positive regulation
needs two things.
Once again, it needs a protein.
This one has given the name CRP.
And, again, it's something
that's able to bind
to a sequence in DNA.
And then it's also
got a conditionality.
It's able to recognize
something else.
And what this one recognizes
is this small molecule that's
known on cyclic
A&P. It's just the
familiar [ribomonophosphate?
that you've seen
before but it's looped around
and formed an ester bond here.
And that's why it's
called cyclic A&P.
But the important
thing about this
is that the levels of cyclic
A&P are dependant on glucose.
So if you have high glucose
you have low cyclic A&P
and if you have low glucose
you have high cyclic A&P.
And here again is
what's going to happen.
So this is the
promoter for LacCYA
and here's the start
of the lacZ gene.
And I told you this is where
the operator would be finding.
This CRP protein is
able to bind to -- --
a site that's even a little bit
farther upstream of the LacC
gene than is the promoter.
And the idea of this is that
if this CRP [lacs?] -- --
just by itself, it
doesn't bind to the DNA.
But it has a little
binding pocket that
senses the levels of cyclic
A&P. So if the cell is starving
for glucose, there are
high levels of A&P,
then the CRP bound to cyclic
A&P, this is capable of binding
to this sequence.
So that sounds weird,
but what we've, again,
got now is we've got a protein
whose binding to DNA is
conditional to something
inside the cell.
And rather than getting
in the way, what
this does, if you
have a situation where
you have CRP with
cyclic A&P bond to it
and it's next door to this
promoter, what it's able to do
is help RNA polymerase
recognize the promoter.
So this helps RNA polymerase.
Whereas, when we were talking
about the lac repressor what
it was doing, if you
recall, was getting
in the way of RNA polymerase.
And this actually has a
relatively simple sort
of molecular explanation
for what's going on.
The RNA polymerase -- The best
sequence for the minus ten
region of the promoter, that
I showed you over on the other
board, is something with
the sequence TATAAT.
So the RNA polymerase
machinery, it
can recognize more
than one sequence,
but if it sees a promoter that
has a minus ten region that
is TATAAT, it really
binds well and that
would be a very strong promoter
and you get lots of mRNA.
Now, the LacC promoter
actually has two nucleotides
that are different.
It's TATGTT.
So this is a very weak
promoter without help.
So in this lac system, if
we got rid of lac repressor
entirely so that the promoter
was just exposed all the time,
as I showed you up
here, I've left out
a detail in this first part
in that this promoter is not
very strong.
And we'd only get
a little bit of RNA
and a little bit of protein.
And so what the cell does is if
it knows there is no galactose,
knows there's no glucose around
and cyclic A&P levels are
high then it uses the
binding of the CRP to here
to assist the RNA
polymerase and get on.
I understand this is
a bit complicated.
Some of you probably have it.
Some of you will
be lost and you'll
have to sit and look at your
textbook for a little while.
But it comes down to a couple
of really simple principles.
One is to detect what's
going on the cell makes
a regulatory protein, the
regulatory protein binds DNA
and it also senses something.
And these things can
work in two ways.
They can either bind
DNA and get in the way,
they can be a negative
regulatory element,
or they can bind
to DNA and they can
help something happen and be
a positive regulatory element.
All the rest are just
the details of lac.
And we could spend the
entire course or regulation
and barely scratch
the surface, but it's
one of the huge secrets
of life that cells
are able to individually
turn on different genes
in different ways
at different times,
have rheostats for levels,
coordinate great sets of genes
in response to various stimuli.
OK?
See you on Wednesday.